I mean what is a model I feel like
somebody who knows how to pose oh right
right right they don't know how to pose
yeah can they dance these are some yeah
they can dance for sure yeah he's seen
them dance I haven't seen who you you
make them dance and you're a
photographer that's weird no like at the
club yeah he meets them Oh I thought
during like a head shot she was like
dance dance dance please and they're
like okay so at the club that you see
them dance oh yeah what club uh big
clubs could you get me if I'm in Dallas
could you get me to the club sure you
don't want to go to the clubs this guy
gos to yeah you do no you don't what's
the I work at upscale clubs no he does
not yes I do he works at Maybe One
upscale club and but what's an upscale
what's a down scale down scale is like
where I could die like yeah I don't
those I don't want to I don't want to
die those those are where most of his
models came from were these oh really
yeah as bars way they throw bottles at
each other yeah yeah I don't want to do
that yeah it's pretty cool it's you I
got used to it yeah let me is baby doll
still in Dallas yes it is right I've
never been to that one but is that a
good one it's a good one yeah yeah wait
what's your favorite one there I know
your favorite of all time is in Texas
somewhere bucks no in Houston it was
Treasures but back in the day we used to
go to baby dolls maybe that's I don't
remember anything else is there one
called bucks there's bucks uh ecstasy uh
it's a lot I've been there yeah yeah do
you like it no no but I want to if I'm
in Dallas I would love to go to a club
with you but a oper one maybe
I know a couple good ones yeah would you
go with me too or no I'll go only to
make sure you stay alive cuz I can't
always trust H judgment oh really yeah
you have to you have to keep me alive
then yeah that' be a bummer if like we
were together and I died Hae Hime can't
always see two three steps ahead you
can't play chess no sometimes him is
very like let's just do this thing and
then we're there and everything is going
horribly wrong and I'm like Hae why the
[__] would you bring us here like you
know what I mean instinctually is that
friend that you wake up like in a trunk
just tied
up like God damn it h oh really oh wow
so um we are you do you believe in God
Hae mhm do you yeah I think yeah but I
just don't go to church yeah either do I
I'm just that wasn't the question dude
oh yeah and you believe there's a heaven
that's a 5050 50/50 okay do you think
God is real but Heaven might not be I
don't know I'm agnostic so
so that's I believe I believe in God but
also I'm
ostic there duality in your mind huh I
love this dude yeah I love this dude
right this is that [__] I'm talking
about where you can't really get like a
direct answer yeah yeah I'm Ying but
also Yang that's what you're saying yeah
yeah wow it's intense do you want to
party like with like white people or
black Mexicans what kind of people you
want to party with yeah it sucks that
that's a question when it comes to where
like but in Dallas when when you want a
party you do got to choose is that
divided that div pretty div like Asian
clubs yeah yeah there's this B easy that
I go to and it's like Asian theme think
you'll love it
speak he what's it
called I want to you think I love it
what's it called I think you love it
yeah what's it called uh aai aai aai
it's a why do you what check that out
what is
that they have these in that club yeah
um I think I I think I will like I think
I would because I like it because
there's all the Asian people there no oh
yeah well this is this uh Filipino lady
but she's cool yeah um her name Megan
one Filipino there's only one that hangs
out there her name is Megan she's cool
oh she is okay cool but she brings me
the wrong drinks sometimes okay um so
that's the club I'll go to a Kai it's
like it's behind a uh a sushi kitchen
so you had to walk through the kitchen
and then go to the club a good fell
style yeah like it's Speak Easy that's
dragons like the red dragon um it's a
red
theme yeah that's
not give me that photo right there
that's that's Kai k him did you take
that picture is that a Kai I don't know
been to Kai Kai Texas a Kai Texas that
is Texas it oh let go scroll down go to
that first
photo oh yeah they're Asians I mean that
was like a bunch of mix they're mixed
it's a mixed yeah mix is that a Kai yeah
and you think I'll love it there yeah
okay see the drawing the that's pretty
cool back there you're going to love the
drawing samai
samai that Asian dry you're going to
love it yeah yeah dude I like I want to
take take me to a Hispanic Club a
Hispanic yeah um sure oh yeah for sure
yeah for sure yeah I want to s that
because I don't want to be around that
well the Ballers uh the the bottles here
are pricey you push it back now push it
back uh the but the Mexicans they pretty
cheap 200 bucks for bottles I don't
drink I just want to go and just check
out the vibe I'll be VI yeah I'll play
like you know EDM music but yeah like
you want to party your rocks we'll take
you where you want Bobby yeah yeah our
wings
now go ahead no that's all I was going
to say you look like a Mars VTA guy you
Mars VTA I love Mars Volta it's a band
it's a band oh no okay what kind of
music do you listen to whatever's on MM
no no no
no we're not we're not no we're not
playing that game cool no we're not
playing that game we're not playing that
gun right now right that was so cool man
give me give me your favorite album